i'm uh uh from northern california
and uh a christian raised a christian
didn't always walk that path obviously
uh
i don't know of too many people that
were able to uh stay that true course
for you know just their whole life some
have and that's amazing but i had
internal battles and demons and things
that i had to deal with so
um
but always very conservative by by
nature married my high school sweetheart
right out of high school so we just
celebrated 27 years of marriage
through liberal hell beautiful family by
the way thank you brother thank you
been through hell and back but she held
on
uh i held on and we had faith that god
would pull us through and he did kids
two daughters yeah twenty twenty three
and a half girls
yeah
yep i got two don't look at your daddy's
girlfriend's profile because his
daughters are beautiful by the way so
i'm not looking enough yeah i'm
seriously with you we have a code for
adam
stick to tinder but go ahead please
continue
so uh entrepreneur humble i'm sorry
please didn't get hinges in a way go
ahead entrepreneur yeah entrepreneur
started my first company when i was 20.
uh had some seminar success we're doing
a couple of million dollars a year in
business but when you got internal stuff
in there a lot of money it can turn into
a lot of problems and headaches
so um a long story short getting to
where my kind of uh
social media platform started to grow
and hello to anybody out there on
youtube that's hearing me now because i
was banned about a month ago on youtube
my youtube page was unpublished
but what started it was right after the
third debate between trump and hillary
i'm watching this debate i'm hearing
trump talk i'm hearing hillary talk and
i'd seen and been paying attention to
what i felt the mainstream media was
doing taking clips out of context
against trump and then painting him like
this evil racist guy
when everybody loved trump before he ran
for office as a republican yeah i firmly
believe if he would have ran as a
democrat they would have treated him
like obama like the next coming savior
is how they treated obama and i didn't
vote for him i was trying to wake people
up
i have a chapter in my book when obama
became president i cried
but it was a it was a it was a cry for
uh of remorse because of who i felt
obama was was not the right leader for
our country
but it was it was strange because it was
also mingled with a black man just
became president so it was bittersweet
for you it's very bittersweet yeah more
bitter than sweet
but uh
yeah anyway i tried to wake people up
because for me
i've always believed
and felt and known
the same i think any child does
towards a baby in the womb
a baby in the womb is a baby
whether it's inside or outside the womb
people know that kids know that
and i think science proves that now as
well
so for me
there was no way that i could vote for a
man
that believed that abortion was okay
especially partial birth abortion he
voted in favor of partial birth abortion
obama did he voted against a bill that
would have provided medical treatment to
babies that survived abortions
and
when i when i first
found out he was running for president i
was excited to my mom thank god for good
moms i pray for you
and family to pray for you she said go
research
how he votes on the issues that matter
to you and so when i found those things
out on his stance on abortion i said i
don't care what color he is
he's not getting my vote
and i tried to wait as a conservative
you've uh uh you've grown up in the
church were you
oh i did until i was about
uh 15 16 and started drinking and were
you ever a democrat were you ever on the
left were you ever never really
political when did you become political
at what age
it was probably obama it was it was
before eight because i mean it was a big
thing for the black community
there's a black guy running for
president yeah right and i think most of
the black community kind of woke up to
saying what they did literally pre-2011
you were never you were never in in
politics you didn't follow it mm-hmm
no wow i mean i followed a little bit
yeah oh eight yeah from eight to 12 to
16. i followed it a little bit did i say
what year did i say
i mean oh seven i mean oh seven meaning
campaign he's coming up so did you hear
him speak in o4 uh did you see his dnc
speech okay so
oh six you're not really following any
of this stuff 07 oh my god someone's
gonna be a black president this is
pretty amazing let me start look
following it and then you said
conversation with mom change your mind
you may want to see what
some of his values are yeah and i'm glad
she didn't direct me
she didn't say oh no you can't do this
or you or yes you can do this
which i think is a huge issue especially
in the black community but i think for a
lot of families period where parents
just try to say well you have to do this
because of this yeah and they don't give
their kids the opportunity to actually
think for themselves so when i
researched and found that out i tried to
wake up as many people as i could uh it
was bittersweet when he won and then it
was like okay round two 2012.
are we gonna do this again
and we frickin did it again and it was
just like you know so you weren't a fan
of obama starting in 0.708 no can i ask
you a question and then i want to hear
phil's opinion on this
you said last night being a black man
who's a conservative that a lot of your
family has alienated you right yes do
you mind if we discuss that no not at
all you talked about
the story where you stayed at the trump
hotel and your mom wouldn't go like
what's it like just being a conservative
black man your family's alienating you i
think 90 percent of african americans
vote for obama or approve democrat like
what's that like for for guys like you
go ahead phil i mean i'll be honest like
going back to what you're saying from
last night you know competing at the
olympia i always wanted to stay at a
hotel where i had all the amenities that
i needed and it just happened to be the
trump hotel in las vegas that provided
that i didn't really think much of it
i'm kind of like david like i really
didn't even pay attention to politics
until obama came about at a dope hotel
that was yeah that's really what it was
but you know and his hotels are dope
yeah and they are yeah
yeah they're amazing i was always
treated with great amount of respect
receiving letters from the sun or you
know like hey because i'm there for 10
plus years
but anyway you know um
i i really noticed that
a lot of my family would not meet me
there
starting what year i probably from the
very beginning but i just didn't pay
attention like let's say 2008. so from
2008 i was staying at the trump hotel
right
and you know winning the olympia in 2011
12 13 and so on um not much you know
of them would come through so even free
he would become an oppressor yeah so
like it was very interesting because he
was the the leading the birther cause
against obama i have no idea you know
but i remember
it had to be something she actually
started with hillary right trump didn't
start that birther mm-hmm
if she started it he certainly took it
and ran oh no he ran with it so
definitely asking a simple question like
hey like why are you guys not coming
through and they're like you know your
mom hates trump and i'm like well what
the hell does that have to do with prior
to him running to president like right
before that okay and i'm like what the
hell does that have to do with your only
son actually staying here like for me it
was just about like did the person treat
you wrong no okay at the end of the day
i looked at you know from that on that
day forward as why are people just
hating on this guy you never met him
what policies are you disagreeing with
because i would you know love to be able
to have some understanding and for the
most part most of my family you know
they don't really talk about it
but uh when you talk about like force or
like you know pushing agendas that is
definitely you know a part of you know
family
but i i'm always the type that has
always been in the middle i always just
want to vote like take the names off the
ballot let me look at the actual
policies
and just what do i identify with and
that's how i've always voted very hard
to do by the way we talk about that a
lot here but anyway so fast forward to
where david's at today i mean if you
follow david stuff on instagram david's
got millions of views millions i don't
even it's not even proper to say
millions of views probably hundreds of
millions online views is what david's
got he's all over the place
uh if you're not already following him
you may want to go follow him to see
what he's doing let's put the link below
for folks to be able to find him as well
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]